you're a legend what is a legend well a
legend is a guy who uh
he has some form of accomplishment cass
is the sport right that he plays or
whatever
medium he's howard's a legend i would
say so yes yes what's your story
i mean you're a real man when you were a
kid did you know you had all this
incredible talent
when you were a kid well you know
believe it or not when i was a kid i was
a better footballer and i was a baseball
player i could see that you're short and
stocky yeah but
uh because my father was a football
player and he wanted me to follow in his
footsteps and
to be honest with you it was my mistake
i just didn't like school or i went to
college
yeah pete's now a radio guy i didn't
know that would they throw you out of
baseball
yeah yeah wait for gambling or something
playing
well you weren't playing why did they
throw you out of baseball see i'm glad
he didn't follow the case because uh i
really did
probably more adverse to what's going on
than most people because uh he wasn't
brainwashed
that's right it's hard it's it's hard
it's hard to find his brain
what is it gary speaking of brainwashing
i'm just gonna help you out with some of
the sports stuff pete wasn't um
wasn't playing but he was mad you were
managing uh
the gambling issue was one where they
think that you're gonna then throw the
game or something
that's what that was the issue i was
suspended for baseball for a minute and
i've been on the super bowl howard right
right yeah yeah nothing more nothing but
i was the only guy that you're a bet on
the super bowl yeah and who
yeah and who would know and who would
not do anything against the game
i know you want to all anybody's got to
do is analyze
and and look at my record playing the
game of baseball or managing the game
baseball and there's nothing crooked
there how much fun is it to be a
professional athlete i mean you get to
hang around with guys you hang around
with guys
you go out and play a game yeah you can
drink and stuff eat all you want because
you get exercise the next day
it's first class i mean it's
unbelievable that's that's the problem i
think with athletes today it's
limousines it's jet planes it's private
jets
is it a horrible let down though when
your career is over no no no no
not at all because you gotta remember i
played i played longer than anybody i
played 24 years so
how selfish would i be to say i wish i
still was playing i mean i was in it i
was a manager
i run the show and and as you can
imagine just reading the papers a day
it's a lot harder
it's a lot harder to manage today than
it was in the 70s or the 60s because of
the amount of money the athletes made
that's right so now you're out of
baseball completely that's it any chance
and you don't want to get back in even
if they sent you tomorrow you could get
back in would you care
no because you go back and coach no no
no i'm a fan so that was like the lowest
point in your life but at the same point
now that you're back on top what do you
care well it wasn't the lowest point it
was
exciting for me because i had so many
great young players come through when i
was manager but
listen you should be in the baseball
hall of fame whatever your problems were
in the past
yeah what so hey did they have anything
to do with what he did on the field
has nothing to do with what you did on
the field your record has to be
recognized
it doesn't listen you could go to any
baseball player in this country
and you can find out all kinds of things
about them listen baseball play
exactly so the point is but your record
stands it's a
fantastic record you should be in the
hall of fame end of it do you find uh
do you find yourself under any scrutiny
from the media please
please don't give a damn i could give a
rat's ass what they say about me
i'm sitting here making a living why do
you think the media is like that you
think that
the media is like that because
frustrated because of the money they
don't make no because they're looking
for news they've got to fill a newspaper
every day
and unfortunately negative things uh get
more
they sell more papers it is big news
when pete rose is gambling that is big
news
he's right because when i had the
anniversary in in august of being
suspended for five years
it had two pages in usa today when i had
the anniversary
for five years for breaking the record
you had to have one little paragraph
right you know you know who pete's worst
enemy is really it's a sports writers
it's like these holier-than-thou guys
and they write these articles that peach
shouldn't be in the hall of fame but
you're right
because whatever you did on that they're
the ones that vote though that's the
problem
that's that's how you get in yeah right
they have like 400
and 425 empowering you need 75 percent
of the votes
to get in and they are so pompous that
they feel that they you have to have a
you have to have this impeccable purist
someone repures and how would you write
you're talking about guys that might
make
500 a week that's right look what i've
made for you i want to hand this to you
now it's a plaque it says hall of fame
hall of fame plaque look at it robin
pete rose you're giving him your own
played 24 years charlie hustle look at
it there it is
sir and uh you're going to hang this in
your restaurant
it's for you and i hope you take it with
you and then you'll that is you believe
it
first there's your hall of fame i voted
you there you go thanks howard